on capitol hill the house select
committee investigating the deadly
attack on the u.s capitol has now
subpoenaed house minority leader kevin
mccarthy and four other republican
lawmakers the panel wants to speak to
them about the events surrounding the
january 6 insurrection as the committee
gets ready to present its findings to
the american public perhaps as early as
next month scott mcfarland has more on
this story
a crime and attack unlike any in
american history has led to a
congressional investigation unlike any
other now after nearly 1 000 interviews
the january 6th select committee has its
sights on five republican congressmen
each of whom has refused to appear
voluntarily including the gop leader in
the house kevin mccarthy the committee
knows mccarthy spoke with then president
trump before during and after the attack
something he talked about during an
interview with cbs news on january 6th i
spoken to the president i asked him to
talk to the nation to tell him to stop
this
mccarthy says the current investigation
is not legitimate and the committee
acknowledges these subpoenas mark an
unprecedented moment an attempted coup
and a violent insurrection
at the capitol interrupting the peaceful
transfer of power
are unprecedented events as for the
other members called alabama's mo brooks
gave a fiery speech before trump at the
white house ellipse january 6. today is
the day american patriots start taking
down names and kicking
the committee says ohio's jim jordan
talked to trump on the 6th and texted
white house chief of staff mark meadows
earlier about blocking the electoral
count and that congressman andy biggs
and scott perry were both involved in
discussions related to efforts to
overturn the 2020 election this is all
about distracting america from their
abysmal record of running america into
the ground
all five congressmen have criticized the
subpoenas and called the committee
polarized with seven democrats and two
republicans the committee hasn't said
what happens if these congressmen defy
the subpoenas whether they'll be
referred for contempt of congress but we
do know the committee's first hearing is
june 9th with a final report likely
weeks later
dana
all right scott thank you and